welcome everybody to today's meeting of
the licensing subcommittee
prior to this week all participants have
previously checked that they can be seen
and heard
and we can see here all the other
members
to double check this and to introduce
everyone who is present at this remote
meeting i would currently ask you
confirm your attendance and your role or
job title when i say your name
uh can we start off with you james mr
clapton
okay so i'm democratic services
lieutenant council
and i'm here to take the emails thank
you
uh mrs stocker good morning everyone my
name is alison stocker i'm the senior
licensing officer for the
district council thank you mr spokes
thank you chair morgan sprouts
regulatory services manager and a
district councillor
thank you mrs phillips good morning
i'm jennifer phillips i'm the litigation
solicitor for um furniture council
and myself councillor potts i'm on the
licensing board and i'm chair of this
meeting today
uh councillor scobee
yes i'm here thank you councillor wing
yes i'm here thank you chief thank you
pc greg
pc greg uh offers her apologies
unfortunately she's unable to make
today's meeting
that's fine uh is pc didn't with us yet
obviously not pc goes foreign
good morning i'm mark barrett um i'm
police sergeant
uh for licensing for kent police um
michelle as i said offers her apologies
so i shall be
representing ken police in this case
that's fine we also know that mr day
will be with us hopefully later and
mr craig yes good morning i'm here to
represent the license holder somebody
has
joined the private court i don't know if
that's mr day or not but
anyway if it's not all that's like good
morning everybody
good morning right i think i have
everyone if you have any technical
difficulties during the meeting
then please contact the democratic
services officer on call
who will attempt to assist you they will
put their phone number in the chat
function i would also ask participants
when you are not speaking to please move
to your microphone this does minimize
background noise and will help everyone
in listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
briefly indicate on the chat
to the right side of the screen and i
will then make a note
and go back to you once the person
speaking has finished
environment would everyone present
please ensure that their mobile phones
are turned to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
calls
whilst the meeting is in progress do not
turn off your phones in case you need
to contact in the event of technical
difficulties
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business
and ensure that you are in a quiet room
free from distractions during
the duration of the meeting okay
gender item number one apologies for
absence we've already had
a couple and
no other apologies chair okay
agenda item two declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
now we've gone to agenda item three
exclusion of press in public
please can i have a member propose
another and a second
that the press and public be excluded
from the meeting for a gender id form
as it contains exempt information as
defined
in paragraph seven of part one of a
schedule 12a
of the local government act 1972 as a
member
as amended so please going to have a
proposal
counselor scope he proposes can i have a
seconder
that counselor wing that's perfect